[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour un nouveau numéro du
7-8 europe le dernier avant les
élections européennes du 26 mai prochain
et à cette occasion nous vous proposons
une émission un peu spécial durant la
prochaine demi heure avec nos deux
invités en plateau nous allons tenter de
vous montrer l importance de ce scrutin
vous expliquer le rôle d'un
parlementaire européen et plus largement
du parlement européen une institution
dont les pouvoirs politiques s'amplifie
depuis sa première élection au suffrage
universel de 1979 mais toujours méconnu
des électeurs l'abstention frôle les 60
% en 2014
qu'en sera-t-il dans un mois c'est l'une
des questions aussi que nous poserons à
nos invités en plateau erasmus ce nom
vous dit forcément quelque chose le plus
connu des programmes européens s'est
développée depuis quelques années et
c'est ouvert notamment aux jeunes
déscolarisés dans le val de marne par
exemple une centaine d'entre eux ont pu
profiter d'un voyage à l'étranger de
trois mois pour développer leurs
compétences professionnelles et
linguistiques et reviennent ainsi mieux
armés pour le marché du travail en
france
reportage à suivre dans cette émission
vincent couronne bonsoir bonsoir nicolas
docteur en droit public vous êtes
chercheur à lui vs qu l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
vous enseignez aussi à sciences po saint
germain en laye et vous êtes le
rédacteur en chef du site internet les
surligneurs en face de vous il a belle
cousté bonsoir pour ça vous êtes chef du
bureau du parlement européen en france
est forcément très au fait du sujet qui
nous concerne ce soir directement
bonsoir à tous les deux merci d'avoir
accepté cette invitation pour débuter
cette émission je vais débuter par un
exercice pratique peut-être si je vous
propose de répondre à cette critique le
parlement européen ne sert à rien
eurodéputés ça ne sert à rien c'est ce
qu'on peut entendre souvent qu'est ce
que vous répondriez vincent couronne
peut-être pour pour commencer eh bien
écoutez je répondrai que évidemment
c'est fumant
aujourd'hui on est c'est complètement
faux et c'est pas parce qu'on ne les
voit pas ou qu'on voit pas forcément
beaucoup leur travail qui ne sert à rien
bien au contraire et je dirais même que
le parlement européen a probablement une
importance plus grande que le parlement
national
simplement il travaille avec beaucoup
d'avancé et il prépare en réalité
l'avenir il avait écouté ce que vous
partagez cet avis est ce que vous
pourriez aussi l'abonder peut-être alors
tout à fait je partage cet avis l'avis
de vincent ça vous donnera pas le
parlementaire européen aussi à titre
individuel il a un pouvoir plus grand
aussi que le député national pas plus
grand parce que il va adopter des lois
qui vont primer les lois françaises mais
plus grand parce que dans le système
politique européen
il a plus de marge de manoeuvre quand un
député national et ça on le sait peu
c'est à dire qu'il n'y a pas de majorité
et d'opposition parlement européen tout
député européen qui va partir en
partenaire un groupe politique
relativement important va au cours de
son mandat se voir confier un rapport
législatif très important lui même et il
devra composer avec toutes les tendances
politiques plus de responsabilités
exactement il aura forcément des
responsabilités pendant son mandat
européen et sur des dossiers vous l'avez
dit qu'il prépare l'avenir
et aussi parce que on va dire ce que
vote un député européen sera forcément
ensuite voté par un par un député
français votée il sera ou pas forcément
si bon si on adopte la gaule t'es pas
forcément c'est par exemple le règlement
sur le général sur la protection des
données personnelles c'est un règlement
d'application immédiate dans les états
membres
il n'a pas besoin de transposition par
contre il sera mis en oeuvre par la
corniche qui va prendre des sanctions et
des ateliers donc ça c'est un pouvoir
législatif très fort au sein de l'union
européenne au sein des institutions de
l'union européenne aujourd'hui un
parlementaire européen et le parlement
européen est ce qu ont enfin son rôle
ses co législateurs du avec le conseil
de l'union européenne et comment comment
comment ça marche
concrètement qui du coup propose les
textes de loi et qui les votent
concrètement ensuite est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer ça nous éclairer
parce que c'est assez compliqué quand
même les institutions européennes
bon déjà encore on va pas d'accord du
coup la sio si c'est pas très compliqué
d un système
ça fonctionne en réalité à peu près
comme fonction des institutions
nationales c'est à dire qu'on a un
organe exécutif qui fait des
propositions d'actes législatifs et puis
on en derrière pouvoir législatif avec
on peut dire deux chambres une chambre
basse le parlement européen une chambre
haute l'équivalent d'un sénat quels
conseils et qu'ils vont adopter ces
actes législatifs la particularité dans
l'union européenne c'est que normalement
dans une démocratie parlementaire le
parlement peut lui même initié ses
propres lois
en france l'assemblée nationale un
sénateur ça peuvent déposer une
proposition de loi
on sait très bien en réalité que c'est
le gouvernement qui derrière d'un buzz
le plus de projets de loi mais dans
l'union européenne les parlementaires ne
peuvent pas le faire
en revanche ça n'empêche pas que les
députés européens en réalité via le
mécanisme des résolutions puis d'autres
mécanismes qui existent en dans l'union
européenne vont inciter la commission
européenne a déposé des propositions de
d'actes législatifs de l'économie en
europe n écoute c'est à dire c'est ces
injonctions porté par les parlementaires
européens tout à fait la commission et
coûte en réalité la plupart aujourd'hui
des actes législatifs qui sont proposées
par la commission européenne qui pouvoir
exécutif européen ont pour origine une
résolution ou une demande spécifique du
parlement européen ou du conseil est
donc on voit là qu'en réalité ce pouvoir
législatif européen même si formellement
il n'a pas d'initiative législative en
réalité i de manière indirecte
il en a une c'est une critique qu'on
entend souvent d'ailleurs ce manque de
pouvoir parfois des des parlementaires
européens où ça serait encore les chefs
de gouvernement la commission européenne
qui décideraient et les parlementaires
auraient on va dire un mot à dire mais
mais pas plus alors ça on l'a dit sans
pouvoir législatif c'est totalement faux
il vraiment les co législateur avec le
conseil sur le pouvoir d'initiative je
voudrais dire deux choses
c'est tout à fait d'accord avec ce qu'a
dit vincent et je voudrais d'illustrer
par exemple le parlement européen lui
s'il n'a pas le râble terrain le pouvoir
d'initiative et juridique il peut
demander à la commission de faire un
texte et c'est ce qu'il a fait par
exemple sur un texte qui protège les
lanceurs d'alert dans l'union européenne
ces lanceurs d alerte il n'était
traitées que par le biais du secret des
affaires
donc de façon très indirecte et
finalement
pas très intéressante pour leur statut
et donc c'est le parlement européen qui
a fait une résolution demeurant dire il
faut un texte européen puisque ces
lanceurs d'alert ils sont sur des
affaires paneuropéenne on peut penser un
deltour sur les wikileaks
pardon paul ii sur deluxe knicks etc ce
sont les scandales qui on va dire qu'ils
ont fait la une de l'actualité ces cinq
dernières années au parlement européen
dans l'union à mesure sur l'évasion
fiscale et donc on a qu'on a compris
qu'il y avait et qu'il fallait que les
états membres et les mêmes statuts pour
la protection des lanceurs d'alarmé pas
de textes européens
le parlement européen a fait une
résolution extrêmement détaillées et la
commission européenne a fini par
proposer un texte
donc vous voyez que cette initiative
elle existe mais enfin je voudrais dire
pourquoi n'existe pas juridiquement dans
les traités parce que ça une raison
quand même dans le système européen la
commission européenne est la garante de
l'intérêt général
on n'est pas dans le système français
avec dans le système européen on a des
petits et des grands états et donc
l'idée c'est que toute proposition
législative elle va être dans l'intérêt
général de l'union européenne elle doit
pas favoriser certains grands états qui
est comment dire feu imposerait leurs
idées à des plus petits états et c'est
pour ça qu'on laisse l'initiative à la
commission européenne qui est une
institution garante de cet équilibre
donc il ya une raison majeure pour cela
mais en même temps sur des dossiers
importants le parlement européen et
exerce ce pouvoir d'initiative est ce
qu'on pourrait est ce qu'on devrait
plutôt renforcé encore ce rôle du
parlement européen ça a été fait à
chaque fois avec les les traités est ce
qu'on devrait encore le faire pour
peut-être intéressé plus aussi les
électeurs et rendre plus démocratique
encore ceux se ses institutions
européennes moi je pense que oui il
faudrait déjà mon avis un pouvoir donner
un vrai pouvoir peut-être qu'on va
pouvoir se poser sur ce sur ce sujet là
donner un vrai pouvoir d'initiative
au parlement européen des initiatives
législatives parce que là un député
européen doit pouvoir déposer une
proposition de directive ou une
proposition de règlement s'il le fait
indirectement pourquoi pas lui donner la
possibilité de le faire directement à
charge ensuite après à l'ensemble du
parlement et du conseil de l'adopter ou
non mais il me semble que ça permettrait
de donner plus de poids politique aux
députés européens ce qu'il faut sans
doute faire aussi pour le pour améliorer
son fonctionnement c'est lui donner plus
de pouvoir sur plus de matière
aujourd'hui sujet donc il ne peut pas
saisir concrètement par exemple la
défend sa politique étrangère
voilà des sujets sur lesquels il ne
donne qu'un avis consultatif par exemple
sur lesquels n'est que consulter je
pense notamment à la fiscalité aussi où
on décide à l'unanimité au conseil et le
parlement ne fait que donner un avis où
on n'a pas de pouvoirs législatifs réel
et donc de ce point de vue là c'est
intéressant d'ailleurs le parlement
européen ressemble un petit peu au
parlement français parce que le
parlement français sous verre vème
république ce parlement gaulliste qui
compte qu'on a voulu rationaliser n'est
pas compétent pour toutes les matières
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat
français ne peuvent pas adopter des lois
dans tous les domaines c'est un peu le
même sujet au parlement européen en
revanche et s'il ya une chose pour
laquelle le pouvoir du parlement
européen très fort c'est sur le contrôle
qui fait fait qu'il assure la commission
européenne ce et l'autre de ces
compétences justement c'est le contrôle
de la commission européenne et des
institutions européennes en général oui
alors c'est on a parlé du pouvoir
législatif du parlement européen sont
deuxièmes pouvoir c'est effectivement le
contrôle des autres institutions et
notamment de la commission difficile de
contrôler le conseil qui est élu
nationalement avec une légitimité à ces
fortes en revanche quand même une petite
île le conseil et il peut même même
faire un recours en manquement que l'on
peut lui poser des questions
en tout cas ils l'obligent à venir dans
l'assemblée ce qui est pas le cas en
france
vous n'avez pas de président de la
république jean n'a jamais dans le
pathos et le sommet à strasbourg
à chaque social vient en tant que chef
d'état il est invité par contre il va
pas venir à l'assemblée nationale
version pour ça il va convoquer le
congrès voyez donc il ya quand même
c'est quand même un parlement qui matiti
des plus démocratiques que finalement
que le paraphe
le parlement fait que les institutions
françaises et la seule tradition
beaucoup plus de contrôle mais je
voudrais citer un exemple qui va se
passer après les élections européennes
il est un des enjeux des élections
lorsque vous avez un nouveau
gouvernement en france vous avez le
porte parole qui sort sur le perron de
matignon et puis qui vous explique ba
voilà ta ta ta ta ta voix la liste des
ministre sans interrogation sans
discussion possible alors après on
commande etc dans l'union européenne ça
se passe pas comme ça les commissaires
les candidats commissaires qui vont être
proposées par les états membres après
organisé par le présent la commission
qui lui même était déjà sera investi par
le parlement
repères au mois de juillet ils vont être
mis sur le gril pendant des auditions de
3 à 5 heures un peu un l'anglo saxonne
et je pense que vous pouvez demander au
commissaire français actuel l'art
moscovici exactement c'est pas un
exercice facile on sort de là épuisé
avec des questions qui portent surtout
tous les côtés toutes les facettes du
mandat de la compétence du portefeuille
mais aussi de l'intégrité de
l'engagement européen et c'est vraiment
un exercice difficile donc le parlement
de rejeter des commissaires européens
concrètement ça c'est souvent le cas ça
a déjà été le cas ça a déjà été le cas
alors il peut pas rejeter un commissaire
en particulier directement mais il va
refuser de donner son investiture à
l'ensemble de la commission s'il n'y a
pas un changement sur telle ou telle
cause et ça ça a été le cas notamment
d'un commissaire italien qui avait tenu
des propos homophobes locomotive du yoyo
est exactement
donc c'est tout c'est un pouvoir que le
parlement européen a acquis c'est à dire
c'est lui même qui l'a construit yens il
ya une culture de de l'acquisition du
pouvoir compte fins de contrôle du de
l'exécutif qui est très grande
au parlement européen il ay là c'est
lui-même qui a décrit à toute cette
procédure dans son propre règlement
intérieur
donc c'est vraiment une culture qui
n'existe pas dans le parlement national
et pour le coup je pense qu'il faut
rendre hommage aussi sur ce point là à
jacques delors parce que jacques delors
président de la commission européenne
avait pour la
fo a présenté l'ensemble de sa
commission devant le parlement européen
pour une sorte de vote d'investiture
ce qui n'avait jamais été fait
auparavant et ce qui du coup a enclenché
une sorte de tradition démocratique du
parlement européen qui investit
désormais la commission et qui est
maintenant inscrite dans les traités et
voilà c'est souvent une pratique qui
après et est inscrit dans les traités
je voulais revenir sur un pouvoir
formellement place de prêts à boire
parce que je voudrais pas laisser penser
que c'est vous renforcer son pouvoir
jean arthuis qui est président la
commission des budgets c'était un député
français a coutume de dire le parlement
européen a de pouvoir sur les sur la
répartition du budget annuel
mais il n'a aucun pouvoir sur les
ressources sur les recettes et ça c'est
important effectivement que le parlement
européen est plus de pouvoir sur le
l'ensemble du budget de l'union
européenne que l'on peut allouer à
toutes ses dépenses à faudrait quoi une
réforme des traités en 4k fait donc
c'est assez complexe et c'est assez
court terme il faudrait plus largement
il ya un sujet qui se pose qui est la
question des ressources propres de
l'union européenne pas un nouvel impôt
je vous rassure mais peut-être une
taxation par exemple je dis pas ça au
hasard des gaffes à qui pourrait
alimenter le budget de l'union
européenne qui serait moins dépendant
des budgets nationaux
et pour ça il faut aussi donc une
modification des traités ou un caillou
un accord et c'est difficile chez les
gars font c'est que c'était un sujet de
discorde importants notamment entre la
france et l'allemagne mais aussi la taxe
sur les transactions financières dont on
a beaucoup parlé qui finalement ne voit
pas encore le le jour je voudrais
enchaîné sur le nombre de parlementaires
ça peut aussi intéresser les gens on a
en france pour un pays 577 députés au
parlement européen aujourd'hui on à 751
députés dont 74 français normalement
avec le bric site on aura 7 105 députés
après les élections du mois de mai dont
79 français la fois la france récupère
tels que quelques eurodéputés on peut
dire britannique pour résumer ça ainsi
mais ce n'est pas sûr c'est un peu
complexe puisque le bric ne saurait
n'est pas encore sur lui même du coup
quelle sera la situation selon vous
au lendemain du 26 mai prochain on aura
combien de députés français combien de
députés européens
alors aujourd'hui je peux pas vous dire
encore les britanniques peuvent toujours
annuler les élections s'ils acceptent
avant le 22 mai avant le 22 mai s'ils
acceptent l'accord de retrait c'est la
condition donc l'objectif sera effectif
avant le 22 mais voilà si le break city
ne sont plus membres de l'union
européenne ils peuvent ne pas faire des
élections s'ils sont encore membres de
l'union comme ils sont obligés de faire
des élections et ils s'y préparent
donc oui il ya déjà une campagne qui est
lancé visiblement ce sont plutôt les
eurosceptiques ou europhobes qui sont en
tête des sondages en grande bretagne en
tout cas il ya une participation record
qui est annoncée donc c'est déjà quelque
chose de cette opération tandis qu'en
france donc ça montre que quand on
manque d'oxygène on va dire l'oxygène
qu'on respire serait l'union européenne
à laquelle on vit et bat peut-être que
on se dit tiens c'est important d'aller
voter dans un corps comme dans un autre
en tout cas si le royaume uni c'est bien
parti pour participer aux élections
européennes on retrouve les chiffres
d'avant la répartition qu'on a de fait
des sièges d'escalier je voudrais
souligner un petit aspect qu'on oublie
toujours de dire on n'a pas seulement
réparti les sièges des 74 britannique
on a aussi réduit le nombre de
parlementaires oui parce que ça on passe
par 750 et 1 à 7 à 5 505 regarderai les
députés européens pour les éventuelle
intégration au sein de l'union
européenne pour pas augmentés des
misères démesurément le parle je crois
d'ailleurs qu'il ya que 751 sièges au
sein du parlement européen je dire
physiquement il y en a eu un peu plus il
ya un peu plus d'une heure après son
fabuleux
le chiffre que vous avez toujours les
sièges la commission du conseil des
mystiques lille est assez grand et on a
on l'a prévu à ces grands aussi mais de
toute façon il ya un chiffre au delà
duquel on ne peut pas les
aujourd'hui il semblait alors exactement
on gère pas une assemblée 2000 députés
c'est compliqué je pense mon
investissement de certains députés
français au parlement européen
à mon avis un strapontin en petit
tabouret leur suffira alors s'il ya un
programme aujourd'hui européen est un
projet qui prouve l'intérêt du sujet
continental et qui rencontrent aussi un
franc succès depuis son lancement en
1987 c'est erasmus le programme s'est
élargie depuis cinq ans pour ne plus
limiter aux seuls étudiants désormais
apprentis formateur et demandeurs
d'emploi peuvent en profiter c'est le
cas de jeunes du vol demain qui sont
partis grâce aux missions locales du
département
en europe on les a rencontrés à leur
retour regardez ce reportage
ils sont à peine rentré que c'est déjà
l'heure du premier bilan pour mon bien
j'ai le même projet la finalité on va
dire en tout ils sont une dizaine de
jeunes est reparti pendant trois mois à
l'étranger espagne allemagne ou en
angleterre ils ont réalisé sur place un
stage professionnel
objectif renforcer leurs compétences et
découvrir une nouvelle culture
franchement on est jeune on a l'occasion
et si voilà si on a
son la capacité aussi si on peut le
faire et franchement moi je le
conseillerai je conseillerais c'est une
expérience que ce soit pour expérience
personnelle ou expérience linguistique
c'est à faire une expérience à faire
donc est rendu possible grâce à erasmus
plus depuis 2014 le mythique programme
européen c'était large et aux demandeurs
d'emploi une aubaine pour des jeunes
comme shirin qui souhaitent devenir
agent immobilier son expérience en
espagne lui offre déjà de nouvelles
opportunités
c'est d'avoir une expérience à
l'étranger c'est un plus vraiment quelle
considérable j'ai plus d'offres d'emploi
en fait déjà cette semaine j'ai passé
plan d'entretien la semaine prochaine
j'en ai encore donc franchement c'est
niveau professionnel ça a été ça a été
vraiment un gros un gros chiffre en fait
proposé par les missions locales du val
de marne est financé en partie par
l'union européenne ces stages à
l'étranger ont profité depuis deux ans à
une centaine de jeunes sortis du système
scolaire ils se rendent compte qu'ils
sont capables avant il l'était il s'en
rendait pas compte
il sortait pas de leur zone de confort
il en avait pas besoin là-bas y voilà il
était dedans ils ont pas eu le choix
donc bah ça leur sert alors parfois pas
dès le retour puis s'en rendent pas
compte mais après plus tard ils ont
acquis des connaissances qu'ils
n'avaient pas ils savent rebondir plus
facilement
ils se débrouillent lors de l'année
scolaire 2017-2018 plus de 78 mille
français sont partis en europe grâce au
programme erasmus ses 26 me de plus
qu'il ya trois ans je voudrais après ce
reportage
aborder avec vous la question de
l'abstention souvent on dit que les
électeurs ne se sentent pas suffisamment
européens ça pourrait expliquer le
manque d'entrain pour aller voter
erasmus tente de combler ce manque là
est ce que c'est ça c'est cette culture
open c'est ce sentiment d'être européen
qui manque aujourd'hui au sein de
l'union européenne et comment on
pourrait le comble est selon vous même
s'il sait pas forcément votre spécialité
avoue universitaire mais vous devez
avoir un indicatif il y a
la question de la question de
l'existence ou pas d'un espace public
européen est très souvent derrière
l'espace public européen on pense à la
question du peuple est ce qu'il existe
un peuple européen a très clairement non
il n'existe pas de peuple européen
aujourd'hui il ya des peuples mais le
traité lisbonne a quand même apporté une
avancée intéressante à dire que avant de
traiter lisbonne le parlement européen a
été inscrit dans le temps et dans les
traités que le parlement européen était
composé de représentants des états
aujourd'hui est que le traité de
lisbonne le parlement où le parlement
est composé des citoyens de l'union
européenne
donc là on a un changement déjà entre ce
qu'ils avaient avant est ce qu'il ya
après le traité lisbonne donc on a
aujourd'hui un parlement européen qui
est censé représenter les citoyens qu'il
les représente véritablement et non plus
simplement les citoyens des états
maintenant l'absence d'un peuple
européen souvent été vu comme un
problème je pense pas que ce soit un
problème que ça parce que quand on pense
à peuples européens très souvent en tant
que le français ou allemand on pense
très souvent un peuple une nation en
réalité est ce qu'il ya une nation
européenne certainement pas mais 7,7 ce
rapprochement entre peuples et nations
vient souvent en fait dans la révolution
française très simplement à l'époque où
la bière est l'abbé sieyès disait que le
peuple c'est la nation lorsqu'il ne
définit teske et côtières et a et c est
le problème c'est connu européenne s'est
construite contre les états nations et
contre évidemment le nationalisme alors
la nation c'est très beau lorsque la bce
laissant pas lorsque ernest renan par
leicester à lens a un grand discours
qu'il avait fait à la sorbonne la fin du
19e siècle mais en réalité entre les
mains des politiques c'est pour dire une
arme d'auto destruction massive se
développant les amuseurs en vouloir
sept nations européennes où cette idée
européenne de disons que ça sera diction
avec l'idée même de construction
européenne par contre il faut l'espace
public européen ça j'étais vidé probable
comme erasmus par exemple aussi tout à
fait ce genre de choix il faut créer des
interdépendances entre les européens
c'est tout l'objet de l'intégration
européenne
hélas les élections européennes peuvent
avoir un enjeu c'est par exemple des
listes transnationales c'est quelque
chose qui pourrait faire en sorte que au
lieu qu'on ait des débats est à tiko
nationaux lors des européennes comme on
l'a aujourd'hui
des têtes de listes nationales dans
chaque état on aurait des listes
européennes avec vraiment les têtes de
listes européennes on a le mécanisme
spécial candidate aujourd'hui mais qui
ne fonctionne pas comme on voudrait
qu'il fonctionne mais voilà ça c'est un
des éléments qui pourrait renforcer
cette cet espace public européen
il avait le cou sté sur cette question
sur l'abstention alors moi je crois
qu'il ya d'abord il faut se poser la
question pourquoi les gens s'abstiennent
ya plusieurs raisons de l'abstention aux
élections européennes surtout pourquoi
on va voter aux européennes quand on
regarde dans nos sondages les raisons la
première raison c'est parce que on fait
son devoir civique
parmi les gens qui votent à toutes les
élections cela vote même élections
européennes et puis dans les facteurs
qui arrive très vite un facteur de
sentiment d'appartenance à l'union
européenne donc c'est vrai c'est vrai
qu' un des facteurs de vote c'est de se
sentir appartenir à un ensemble européen
après ce qui est important aussi c'est
pas les enjeux nationaux qui prime
aujourd'hui quand on va voter même aux
élections européennes lors si justement
mais j'arrive aussi à cette question là
il ya d'autres facteurs qui expliquent
pour ce coup-ci l'abstention c'est le
fait qu' on connaît ce mal les enjeux
européens
on se dit mais pourquoi je vais voter
ces élections deuxièmement on ne sait on
a c'est un peu ce qu'on a dit tout à
l'heure une vision du parlementaire qui
a peu de pouvoir parce qu on y colle le
système français et or le parlementaire
européen
on l'a dit tout à l'heure il a un vrai
pouvoir dans le système de l'union
européenne et les élections on est
habitués en france que l'élection la
plus importante c'est la présidentielle
qui va démarrer tout le processus
d'élection municipale aussi éliminer ces
pâles et missy par celle à proximité
mais parlons au moins en tout cas de
celle qui le plus loin mais qui est un
enjeu est peut-être politique pas plus
important parce qu'ils sont très
importants pour municipal aussi mais les
européennes c'est une sorte de
l'élection législative qui va démarrer
tout le processus
on se trompe andrade élections c'est pas
une élection parmi des élections
nationales c'est l'élection centrale
pour l'union européenne pour démarrer
échanger tout système c'est un peu la
présidentielle de l'europe en quelque
sorte parce qu'après les parlementaires
européens
ils vont élire le président la
commission et tous le renouvellement des
institutions va découler de la et
notamment les orientations politiques
qu'on va donner à la construction
européenne
elle démarre de ces élections donc on
sait
ça en france alors on a l'habitude
qu'une pas une élection législative
c'est pas si important que ça or là
c'est une élection législative
européenne qui a rang des élections
présidentielles en france on va dire en
quelle est donc il faut aller voter je
lui ai rappelé peut-être les chip n'y a
pas de pas de soucis près de 58% des
électeurs se sont abstenus en france en
on peut féliciter les yvelinois c'était
54% dans seulement ce sont les chiffres
du ministère de l'intérieur
si on fait un peu de projection et pour
terminer cette émission il nous reste
deux minutes lors de la prochaine
mandature qui va donc cette année de
2019 à 2024 quels seront les thématiques
que vont devoir porter discuter les
parlementaires européens selon vous la
précédente mandature ça a été beaucoup
la question sécuritaire avec les
attentes a évidemment qui ont touché
toute l'europe selon vous même si vous
n'avez pas de boule de cristal est ce
que vous avez des idées sur le sujet qui
vont être débattues
alors il ya déjà un dossier qui de toute
façon est laissée au prochain parlement
parce que il a été on n'est pas arrivé à
le régler pour l'instant c'est à la
question nous en parlait tout à l'heure
du budget de l'union européenne pour les
7 ans qui viennent et c'est pas une
petite question parce que c'est de là
que découle tout les autres politiques
comme il élégamment les fonds européens
qu'on avait notamment les fonds
européens qui donnent aux portes des
actions comme comme vous l'avez montré
cette question d'habitude à les régler
juste avant les élections européennes
et là on l'a on la réussite ça c'est
vrai que effectivement un peu coincé des
choses dans la mesure où on doit trouver
les milliards d'euros nécessaires qui
manque à la contribution de la
contribution britannique donc on doit
faire des choix
donc ça c'est une question qui devrait
être réglé à l'automne 2019 2020 les
députés européens vont immédiatement
rentrer dans le bain et puis il ya tout
un tas de questions qui ont été laissées
en suspens sur des dossiers législatifs
très important du parlement européen je
pense à à l'autorité
europe enfin l'autorité du travail la
réforme de la pac il y aura quoi
effectivement de quoi travailler 30
secondes si vous voulez oui sursaut je
suis tout à fait d'accord
est-ce que d'isabelle postés sur les
priorités après le ce que j'ai envie d'y
assez que les priorités sont celles de
la majorité qui sera aussi en place à ce
moment-là il y a depuis quelques
décennies au parlement européen une
majorité qui est plutôt à droite
si les français et leurs aises européens
votent pour toujours une majorité à
droite ils auront une politique qui sera
celle mise en place par cette majorité
là si ils veulent une autre politique
européenne ils ont qu'a voté pour
d'autres politiques d'autres partis
politiques alors il ya les socialistes
il ya les écologistes il ya les
centristes et serra il y à tout un tas
d'autres possibilités et ce sont eux qui
vont aussi fixer l'agenda et c'est un
des pouvoirs d'ailleurs assez incroyable
du parlement européen c'est que il fixe
son ordre du jour contrairement à
l'assemblée nationale merci à tous les
deux d'avoir participé à cette émission
c'est la fin de ce set 8 europe
consacrée aux élections européennes du
26 mai vous pouvez toujours vous forger
un avis sur le continent sur les enjeux
des élections en consultant notre page
est dédiée à l'europe sur notre site tv
soixante dix huit points comme merci
encore à vous et à très vite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]